this is day 20 i'm putting weird stuff
in burgers until we get bored
oh you got my attention
do you know the compost you have to do
it always
trying to cook chicken by slapping it
part one so there's this meme that says
you can cook a chicken
you slap it fast and hard enough
flapping faster need to be roasted
how do you recover from that again
tell me you're gonna get right together
[Music]
absolutely cooking steaks for the last
three decades
[Music]
you don't put red lettuce on a burger
kid how many times i told you
are they handlers on your belt yes
the butter will burn in seconds
especially that harder
no chop the guy like that it will burn
as well more blue
come on that thing looks radioactive
hold on a minute
deep fat frying it dude right now i want
to stick your head in the deep
frying doughnuts
you're not going to cook the burger
gina how many times i've told you leave
the cooking to me recovered from
[Music]
and then finishing butter wrong way
around big boy
wrong way round three is that a
seasoning belt we've got on
pancetta it's called bacon your donut
come on man how many times i was showing
you how to make a freaking burger
and now look what you're doing
vinegar oh no come on they got a better
burgers in iceland
and island four you have to be kidding
me
honestly what a freaking donut so we let
it run
[Music]
you should be ashamed young man honestly
what would your parents say
go put the butter after see her first
come on big man make sure they rest
before you slice them otherwise
all the goodness will run out come on
big boy you're supposed to be a steak
expert
hit me man what are you doing
hey seriously seriously
have you got too many bears in that
seasoning belt
ready oh no eating animals is wrong
gordon ramsay
hurting animals is wrong gordon ramsay
share
this song and
[Music]
you